am 28 april 2020 wird die leiche von
andrea k aus der weser nahe dem
niedersächsischen balke geborgen
sie ist nackt ihre hände sind auf dem
rücken gefesselt an ihren füßen wurde
eine betonplatte gebunden
die obduktion ergab dass die zweifache
mutter noch lebte als sie unter wasser
gezogen wurde
sie ertrank andrea wurde opfer eines
grausamen verbrechens für den fall
analytiker mark t hofmann ist der mord
an andrea k ein fall mit mehreren täter
motiven
man hat ein seltsames eine seltsame
mission aus beziehungstat aber auch
klaren bezügen zur illegalen
prostitution und gerade wenn es mehrere
täter gibt kann sich das durchaus
mission aber der hass der in diesem
verbrechen doch deutlich wird deutet
darauf hin dass es auch eine persönliche
verbindung gibt dass es auch eine
beziehungstat ist das heißt hier besteht
kaum ein zweifel dass das nicht wahr was
impulsiv aus einem streit heraus spontan
passiert ist sondern dass dies eine
geplante ein geplanter mord oder man
muss leider fast aufsagen in richtung
war
[Musik]
ein besonders tragischer fall christin
weil meine kollegin ist jetzt in
helmstedt vor ort zweifache mutter wurde
heute beerdigt system was gibt es neues
zum ermittlungsstand laut
staatsanwaltschaft in verden laufen die
ermittlungen weiterhin an als sie sind
andauernd
mittlerweile wurden vier tatverdächtige
festgenommen drei männer und eine frau
unter anderem gilt als hauptverdächtiger
stefan k ein mutmaßlicher zuhälter aus
nienburg des weiteren in
untersuchungshaft ist diego de der
ex-freund von andrea k
laut bild informationen soll er sie zur
prostitution gezwungen haben und er
wollte sie auch an den mutmaßlichen
zuhälter stefan k verkaufen also noch
dauern
dauern die ermittlungen an wenn man sich
diesen fall anguckt so wie es auch schon
in den beitrag gesagt wurde ist es eine
mischung aus beziehungstat man das
verhältnis von diego de zu andrea k
sieht und es ist ein verbrechen der
organisierten kriminalität also es gibt
eindeutige zeichen und ermittlungen die
ins rotlicht-milieu führen
ja wir werden weiter in diesem fall
dranbleiben christin herzlichen dank
nach helmstadt